i i figured that i would just drop in
real quick and remind everyone that even
i got you a wedding gift it's in the
mail uh you will appreciate it i think
most of the other guys will appreciate
it your wife will hate me because of it
but that's okay hey do you want me to do
you want me to return this because times
are tough right now do you want to wait
for bitcoin to go back up like what's
going on well actually i uh didn't pay
for it in bitcoin because bitcoin has
been dropping so rapidly that i was
scared so instead i just used the fiat
and uh and figured out that uh that'd be
a better uh purchase decision okay well
i just want to let everybody know who
we're talking to we're talking to the
king of bitcoin right now anthony
pompliano uh we had a great podcast down
in miami i think it really
uh well it caused bitcoin to drop again
so the first time i we literally within
like 48 hours he convinced me to buy a
bitcoin at its peak and then it dropped
48 hours afterwards that being said i
still love this man he's a great dude
he's hilarious on twitter i love to see
you fighting with people and you look
great i like the five o'clock shadow i
need to give some compliments to you i
need to build you up because half of
your net worth is in the tubes right now
you've lost probably hundreds of
millions of dollars okay lord
studio the only thing worse than having
a majority of your net worth in bitcoin
and watching it go down 50 percent is
being akash and having it all on
dogecoin and having that go down easy
[Laughter]
hey pump i ain't getting a wedding gift
[ __ ] i'm still tripping on that
you clout trout
he gets a gift i don't
listen i'll send you one too but here's
the only thing is if i send you the same
thing that he got then i want both of
you to see who can use it best that's
all i'll say but if you send me your
address i'll send you one as well
done
he said your wife will hate you my wife
is gonna hate this might be a flashlight
listen you just sent me all of the
addresses from mark is married
okay mark is married alex might get
married soon double never get married
so three more dates
who didn't get the uh wedding gift by
the way uh duff
oh wow yeah i had a year to do it and
i'm at the point where i can't just give
cash now i have to be creative
i can't give a coin i can't give cash if
you give bitcoin it costs 50 percent
less than it did last year there you go
there's a deal you're saying
for you buddy okay now let's get to the
let's get to the bottom of this uh pumps
explain to us i've watched some youtube
videos i don't know what the [ __ ] these
guys are talking about but apparently
there are some strategic decisions being
made by government that is affecting the
price of bitcoin is that true or false
well first of all most of the people on
youtube don't know what they're talking
about either so we're all in good
company in terms of myself you everybody
else nobody knows what they're talking
about that's all let's clear that up
second thing is uh yes basically the way
to think about this is over the last two
years since the pandemic started uh the
government the central bank etc they
basically said hey there's massive
issues remember in 2020 there was like
six million people a week filing for
unemployment uh everyone thought the
world was ending the stock market sold
off 30
like literally armageddon and so they
stepped in and they just flooded the
market with cheap capital all that means
a fancy way is just saying they
literally just stuffed the money in
every corner they could they were
handing it out like it was candy right
they gave extra unemployment benefits
they gave ppp uh payments they gave
stimulus checks literally we had
billionaires going on cnbc saying yo i
got a twelve hundred dollar check how
does that happen there's giving money to
everybody well when that happens
basically money is it's like monopoly
money it's free money so whatever they
do they go and they invest in the market
and asset prices explode and so when the
fed and uh the politicians do this it's
monetary and fiscal policy they
basically ease meaning that they make it
easier to get capital and so asset
prices go up uh but at some point they
can't do that because at the same time
that asset prices are going up so are
consumer goods this is where inflation
comes in so if you think about inflation
inflation happens to assets and also to
consumable goods so if food's up six
percent and the stock market's up 30
in the last 12 months well guess what
happens rich people get richer and poor
people get poorer because poor people
spend all their money on the consumables
and rich people put all their money in
investments and so ultimately now
they're like oh [ __ ] the elections are
coming up in november we probably
shouldn't go into an election season
with seven eight percent inflation let's
get that down and so now they haven't
even done anything yet all they've said
is we're gonna make it harder we're
gonna tighten we're gonna taper we're
gonna raise interest rates we're gonna
make it harder to get cheap capital and
so all these rich people say like oh
[ __ ] that sounds bad so they just go
sell all their investments in the risky
stuff and they go back into the safe
stuff so they're selling off text stocks
growth stocks they think bitcoin is
risking their portfolio if you're on
wall street and so now that they're
going back into the safe stuff things
like berkshire hathaway value investing
you know cash etc and that's why you see
all the uh kind of rarest gas that's all
the things that young people have been
buying that's all going down in price
because everyone's basically selling
risk assets and buying value stocks and
that's why berkshire hathaway hit an
all-time high last week so it's
literally just a rotation of capital
where people say hey get rid of the
risky [ __ ] and go get the uh the stuff
that we deem safer and they were willing
to take that risk before because they
were dealing with essentially like free
money or close to free money exactly
gotchu so that's not gambling because
hey if somebody gives you 30 000 ppp
loan you're basically throwing it in the
market if the market's going to be up
even 10
then you'd be able to pay that back no
problem
yeah go think of it this way there's
only three major hedge funds on all of
wall street last year that beat the s p
so like the beta like the market
standard of the s p 500 went up almost
30 percent only three hedge funds these
folks are paid millions of dollars a
year they manage all this money they
couldn't beat the benchmark because
literally it was just exploding upwards
and so when you think about that like
that's a crazy stat the crazier status
there's 35 politicians in congress and
senate who beat the s p 500 but we won't
go there
the hedge funds had a hard time beating
just a benchmark and so ultimately what
you get now is there was good times
people are scared now one of the things
to remember about kind of assets
inflation and the fed all this kind of
crazy exotic complex stuff is a lot of
times they just say things to get people
to react so for example inflation one of
the big fears is if all three of us uh
start yelling and screaming and we're
like inflation's coming inflation's
coming inflation's coming what do people
do they're like well [ __ ] i'm not gonna
wait for it to get here they go and they
move their capital in anticipation of it
if i'm a business owner and i think
inflation's coming i raise my prices
right i i try to front run the inflation
which ultimately causes inflation yeah
the same thing happens now is they
basically want asset prices to come back
down to normal levels they want things
to kind of cool off so if they start
talking about you know the end is coming
we're going to raise rates we're going
to tape or we're going to do all this
what do we all do we all go sell our
risk assets right we go rotate into uh
kind of value type investments and
therefore in some way just talking about
it ends up actually creating the impact
that they want
and so my guess is that they're going to
talk a really big game they're going to
posture like you know we're going to do
all this crazy stuff they'll do some of
it but they already a lot of the damage
right in terms of the in the market has
already happened and they haven't even
done anything yet just by talking about
it they were able to accomplish that now
best case scenario is this them trying
to implement
a policy or even a fear tactic so that
there's not a massive
correction in the market are they
basically trying to get capital
reallocated so that the market itself
doesn't reallocate it in some crazy
crash
yeah i think that they know when they
start talking about this there's going
to be some sort of market correction
some sort of uh you know you can call it
a crash whatever really what we've
watched happen is certain sectors are
getting hit really hard like technology
stocks and growth stocks uh but there's
other sectors of the market like a
berkshire hathaway the kind of value
type investments those are benefiting
from this so ultimately what you see is
they basically saw okay things are
really hot but
the federal reserve basically has two
jobs right they want stable prices and
they want full employment they're not
supposed to be worried about asset
prices now one of the big things that
you know maybe comedians could talk
about uh but the average person would
kind of get their finger shaken at them
is we had federal reserve members of
power and influence that have literally
quit their jobs or been fired or pushed
out because they were day trading the
same assets that they was buying last
year yeah like like these dudes like
this is like the one of the biggest uh
you know kind of controversies it's one
of the biggest issues and everyone's
just like oh yeah like those federal
reserve guys had to quit because they
were day trading the same assets they're
buying like what's going on what is the
argument for the legality of that i know
you see like nancy pelosi gets
criticized a lot for this i'm sure
there's a bunch of other politicians
like why are they allowed to make trades
given the insider information they have
and by insider information i just want
to clarify i'm not saying that they know
what the company can do but they can
implement policy that will affect the
decisions of those companies why are
they allowed to take place in that
marketplace
i think there's a couple of different
participants here so one is let's say uh
people in appointed positions these are
like the federal reserve central bankers
people who the american people don't
elect but the politicians we elect then
appoint them to that position so those
individuals for the most part they are
creating monetary policy decisions that
end up impacting the market they also
are going into the market via
quantitative easing and buying certain
types of assets so mortgage-backed
securities etc what happened over the
last you know six months or so is
multiple members of the central bank
system were found out to have been
literally day trading those assets and
so if your institution is buying the
same asset that you're day trading on a
daily basis like a lot of people are
like yeah that doesn't sound so great
right so like that's issue number one
what you're talking about is the elected
officials so these are congressmen and
senate uh members who are actually
buying and selling
stocks individual stocks uh but it's not
just buying and selling i think most
people in america would say you know
what we don't want our politicians to be
worried about money all the time so if
they were quote unquote rich then they
could just worry about governing and
they wouldn't be worried about where
their paychecks coming from the problem
is that not only are they buying and
selling individual stocks at very
opportunistic times you know let's go
buy microsoft five days before it's
awarded a billion dollar you know
federal contract using that as kind of a
hypothetical but actual rooted in some
level of reality but they're also doing
it with like exotic financial
instruments they're not just buying the
stock they're like buying it levered
with options and uh kind of all kinds of
crazy things that these are career
politicians
what is a career politician doing being
worth 20 40 50 60 million dollars and
they have better investing track records
than the hedge funds on wall street but
something's going on
and so i think ultimately what's going
to happen here is we've now reached a
point where this is kind of tipped over
and the public narrative is the
politician shouldn't be holding
individual stocks regardless of if
they're actually doing something wrong
or not it's the appearance of
impropriety what we want is we want
politicians who
whether it's true or not we believe are
actually unbiased who are focused on
what they're doing and uh representing
us
so this won't actually change anything
it'll just change the appearance of the
change of perception of things i i bet
you if they change the rules there's a
lot of these old politicians that all
retire
right and if you no longer have the
advantage of getting information uh to
actually become wealthier at some point
it's like yeah why am i why am i
subjecting myself to all this criticism
and all this nonsense and stress i'm not
even getting rich anymore right like
i'll see you guys later yeah
oh so nancy pelosi will do all this
performative [ __ ] you know get on
one knee in the senate floor for black
lives matter as long as she's making
tens of millions of dollars with insider
trading
listen the insider trading thing is like
a term that gets thrown around a lot now
one thing that is true is there's
definitely certain parts of the
financial disclosures where politicians
are treated differently than let's say
ui uh or others the other piece of it is
like what is actually insider trading so
for example if you know that the
government is going to award a contract
uh to microsoft according to the
definition of quote-unquote insider
trading around the corporation
you don't have immaterial uh information
that would have a uh positive impact on
the stock from inside of microsoft you
basically have something externally
right that is going to have an impact so
it's kind of like remember in new york
city remember when they say they're
gonna shut down the l train there was a
bunch of people who were talking about
they said they're gonna shut down the l
and so everyone was moving out of
certain parts of brooklyn and the real
estate prices all crashed right because
they were shut down for a certain period
of time right well at some point they
decided they weren't going to shut down
the l and so some people knew that went
in and bought the real estate and then
they announced the l was coming back
right and the real estate prices shot
back up is that technically insider
trading uh it's like a gray area and so
like should there be rules for that
should there not that's kind of what the
politicians are doing because they're
not necessarily going and talking to you
know satya nadella and microsoft being
like hey what's revenue going to be this
you know this quarter before you
announce it they understand certain
things and then the other thing and the
crazy crazy thing is imagine let's say
you guys are uh i don't know um in the
healthcare industry you guys run a big
corporation i'm a politician and you
basically give me money you fund my uh
campaign you're my biggest donor i then
get into office and now i start
advocating for all sorts of regulation
of your industry
but i personally think that if you get
put in by a certain industry you
shouldn't be allowed to oversee that
industry
right why should we allow people to
actually regulate the industries that
they're dependent on in order to get
into office yeah and so one of the crazy
ideas that uh i've thrown out there
before is like just pay all the
politicians like 5 million bucks a year
literally it's like a drop in the bucket
for the federal budget tell them look
you can't invest anything you can't be
trading stocks you can't do any of this
nonsense just give him five million
dollars a year tell him to shut up and
govern and literally just get rid of all
this nonsense and let's get back to the
important work that they should be doing
rather than us trying to figure out like
why did you know nancy pelosi or anybody
else go
put you know three times levered options
on a company that just got a government
contract and went up 20 and they made a
killing and the average american's like
well that doesn't sound very fair i
think that's the strategy in singapore i
think the uh prime minister or whatever
the guy's name is uh who's in charge in
singapore i think they get paid like
three million dollars a year something
and the idea is i want you to be able to
focus on this and i don't want you
manipulated by outside sources you
should be wealthy enough we trust that
you're gonna do your job but you should
be wealthy enough where you don't need
that extra money
think about this out of all of our
smartest friends right
how many of our smartest friends are
want to be politicians
i don't have a single smart friend now
it's like yo i want to go be a
politician right
it's all the egotistical maniacs that
are like yo i'm going to go be powerful
because i can't be rich in the private
market i actually think you would be a
great politician pomp you know why
because you are deflecting the bitcoin
crash and not really telling us what the
[ __ ] is good this guy is good
this guy is [ __ ] good that was good
that was really good
so listen the whole bitcoin thing is
ultimately it's exactly what you guys
asked about it's a kind of an external
thing if you look at all of the kind of
fundamentals or the underlying data
around bitcoin hash rates at an all-time
high in terms of the network's ever been
more secure there's still 13 billion
dollars a day of on-chain settlement
transaction volume a million active
addresses like people still use it uh in
very very high degree
and all of that is very healthy it's
literally just over the last two to
three years wall street investors
started to own a lot of bitcoin so you
saw everything from banks to hedge funds
to these billionaires etc and now they
treat it very differently than like the
bitcoin community the bitcoin community
sees the price go down they're all
buying right all these retail and
they're like oh [ __ ] it's on sale let me
go buy more but the hedge fund guys or
the wall street folks they treat this as
a risk asset and so in these moments
they're going to sell it and they just
have more money than the retail investor
right and so when they basically have so
much money they just start dumping it
the price falls and retail investors
they'll go they'll scoop up kind of the
cheap bitcoin and we'll see what happens
moving forward but
speculatory question how long do you
think it continues to slide like
theoretically this legislation that
probably won't happen we still got a
couple months out before that sold some
yeah i sold a little bit i'm hoping to
rebuy lower i got sold some he didn't
have diamond hands
when did you sell did you sell your dose
corner you still got that no i never had
doge ever in in my life you're
disrespecting me right now
all right at least give me a wedding if
you're going to disrespect me chain link
which is doing fine chain link yeah yeah
which he dm me to sell and then it shot
up to an all-time high as soon as i sold
some anyway son of a [ __ ] point is i
want to buy lower i got the amount i
want to put in but i was like oh if i
could i just sold it 34 or something
like that and i was like maybe if it
drops to like 25 i could take that money
and buy even more bitcoin with it so
when do you think this slide stops not
necessarily a dollar amount but how much
longer you think it goes i i think that
that's uh almost impossible to answer
with an exact thing here's what i'll
tell you is the last time that we had a
50 drawdown it lasted for about 95 days
or so that was over the summer of 2021
remember bitcoin's dropped 50 four times
in the last four years
so this is now becoming like a pretty uh
regular thing the last one was about 95
days before it bottomed we're in about
75 days or so into this one could it
repeat at 95 sure maybe maybe it's
longer maybe it's shorter nobody really
knows i think that if you look at
actually the best way to
kind of play these things from just like
a pure mathematics standpoint forget
which asset whether it was stocks crypto
anything else
it's just dollar cost average yeah so if
you basically just say hey look i'm
gonna buy a little bit every day and
maybe i get some at the bottom maybe i
don't maybe i'm somewhere around the
bottom you end up actually coming out on
top because you know one thing is for
sure as humans suck at managing their
emotions and kind of timing it right
because you think you'll buy a 25 and
when it gets to 25 like [ __ ] it's going
to 20. right when it gets to 20 you're
going to 15
and next thing you know you don't buy
any and then it's back to 40 and you're
like damn i'm an idiot i sold at 34.
yeah
yeah but you're not an idiot you're
actually uh one of the uh the five
smartest people in that room
hey hey thanks man this [ __ ] smart
ass room dog this is a smart ass room
this [ __ ] guy over here yeah gonna be
spinning pizza over his head talking
[ __ ] yeah you know what happened to
bitcoin pizza pump yeah where's bitcoin
pizza
listen bitcoin pizza you guys actually i
think since you guys are saying
this guy's a politician this guy is a
politician
and you should be promoting it so that
we can take the profits and donate a
bitcoin developer so they can keep
protecting your bitcoin that's what you
guys should be doing we need to i think
there needs to be one pizza box in the
back on the wall or something dude this
guy is ready we want percentages uh wait
you're better buy us cheap bro right
bitcoin 2007. you can't get us cheap
like that
we want [ __ ] percentage dog bitcoin
was launched in 2009. i threw out a
number bro
come on listen your numbers are better
than remember last time i was on and uh
and angela looked at his portfolio and
he thought he was up 14 but really
oh yeah i did do that
berkshire hathaway killing it my boy
i didn't sell any of that berkshire
hathaway
young warren buffett over there i hear
you exactly drinking diet cokes and
[ __ ] kids
allegedly
allegedly allegedly allegedly
i mean it is pretty it is pretty crazy
that uh somebody who's considered the
best investor of the last 50 years who
by the way has been an incredible
investor basically did it buying
everything that now is pretty much seen
as like horrible right in terms of the
financial services where they were money
laundering uh coca-cola candy all this
crazy stuff but uh hey he he did what he
did and here we are uh i just don't know
if that strategy is going to be uh be
the winner moving forward talk that [ __ ]
bro
bro you're the new buffett right now
you're gonna be the new congressman of
omaha
i think that's where we gotta run you
first talk that [ __ ] pump
i i don't know if you can uh be a
politician in omaha nebraska and not be
friends with warren buffett i feel like
that's probably a pretty key person to
get on your side if uh you want to be a
politician there but uh yeah i have zero
interest in the political situation i
think that uh the technologists are just
saying look we this system's broken uh
why don't we just build some tech that
uh could uh could kind of help solve the
problem rather than go and do the
bureaucratic thing okay so you're saying
now is the time to buy basically you
think this thing is coming up i know
that you got to get off the phone
uh but but now is the time to buy this
thing is gonna come back bitcoin will
half
and uh this will continue to repeat and
it is just the trajectory of this weird
commodity that we're now i think i said
it to when when i was on last time right
is that uh my psychological uh kind of
thought process is just the bitcoin i
hold i'm gonna hand to my grandkids one
day and so whatever happens in the short
term frankly doesn't matter right now
it's easy for me to say because i've
been doing this for a while but also
it's just regardless of if bitcoin's at
30k at 35 at 25 at 40. like it only
doesn't matter if you've got a outlook
of 10 20 30 40 years and so i think
people just got to ask themselves like
are you actually a long-term investor or
are you simply thinking in days and
you're trying to trade and you want to
go flip you know this asset into that
asset like that's just not me i'm not
good at it frankly i'll lose all my
money if i try to do that so i just say
look i dollar cost average into it hold
it for a long period of time and you
know so far that's been a pretty good
strategy
pomp
tell us how much money you lost
when
in this in this current having
oh
listen uh if people saw how much myself
or others uh
watched their net worth fluctuate like
yeah you ever seen your net worth go
down 50 in 75 days like well what would
that be what would that be like 50
million would that be like 100 million
like how what would that be what would
half be
i've got uh about half of what you have
so if you'd say what how much you have
then i could say that i've got 50 of
that you have half of what i have where
yeah your net worth i'm like 50 i'm
trying to catch up to you
you think you're worth half i'm gonna
hang up this call if you're with half of
what i have
don't do this to me bob listen i'm
talking to the greatest comedians in the
world right now like you guys are rich i
saw the tour
you guys are on private jets you guys
are flying around the greatest show on
earth like listen to me this guy this is
a real [ __ ] bill clinton
we love you thank you so much for taking
the time my brother come up to new york
and see us soon okay
all right sounds good gosh send me your
uh send me your address
a couple of uh fart bombs and [ __ ] all
right beautiful can't wait baby
[Applause]
you